do you know who you welcomed into your  home  [Music]  we and we embrace it mrs. Ternan hi I'm  Jean pleased to meet you mr. Taylor well  here the beautiful home she is a godsend  I was expecting someone older less weird  we hope you'll treat our house is your  home I'm sure you and Jericho will from  an instant bond  [Music]  she's good with everything she knows the  situation  I guess we should talk about this she's  gone you can put the doll down I'm fine  as I am mr. Jenner  we lost Jericho when he was 13 weeks  darth who took it hard this is the only  thing that brought her back  I should take Jericho for a walk now you  hired a nanny for a doll did you find  her she is wonderful with Jericho and if  my baby trusts her so do i how much did  those boys tell you about what happened  what if she wakes up  what if Hugh were members  [Music]  do you know who you welcomed into your  home  [Music]